From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, and I am joined in the studio by my coworker Emmanuel Dzotsi.
来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》，今天我的同事Emmanuel Dzotsi也来到了录音室。
Hey, Ira.
嘿，Ira。
Hey, there.
你好啊。
So I have come into the studio today with this, actually. Let me just get it out of this bag really quickly. Hang on here.
今天我带着这个东西来到了录音室。让我赶紧把它从袋子里拿出来。等一下。
[BAG RUSTLING]
[袋子摩擦声]
[THUD]
[沉重的落地声]
Uh-- [CHUCKLES]
呃…… [轻笑]
So that is like a piece of rock about the size of a football, yellow on one side.
那是一块足球大小的石头，一面是黄色的。
Mm-hmm. Yeah, it's a piece of concrete.
嗯哼。对，这是一块混凝土。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
So there's a story behind this, which is a couple weeks ago, I went to this one street in Washington, DC, and on that street, there were-- I don't know-- maybe a dozen construction workers who were using all of this heavy machinery to rip out the words "Black Lives Matter," which had been painted on that street as part of this big mural they had done in 2020, right after the murder of George Floyd.
这背后有个故事。几周前，我去了华盛顿特区的一条街道，在那条街上，我不知道……可能有十几名建筑工人正在用重型机械拆除“黑人的命也是命”（Black Lives Matter）这几个字。那是2020年乔治·弗洛伊德被谋杀后，作为大型壁画的一部分被漆在那条街上的。
Yeah, I actually saw that once. This is giant letters, like, 50 feet tall or something, two blocks long.
是的，我以前见过。那些字巨大无比，大约50英尺高，绵延两个街区。
Yeah, it was, like, huge, and right by the White House. And what I was watching that day, as I was there, was the city just completely getting rid of it because of pressure they'd been under from the Trump administration. I thought that when I got there that there would be crowds or protests, but it was pretty empty. Most of the people that I saw just sort of walked past and kept it pushing, ignored what was going on.
没错，规模宏大，就在白宫旁边。那天我在现场看到，由于特朗普政府施加的压力，市政府正在彻底清除它。我本以为到那儿会看到人群或抗议，但现场很空旷。我看到的大多数人都只是匆匆走过，各忙各的，忽视了正在发生的事情。
But then I saw this one Black woman sort of stop and wave over to one of the lone Black guys working on the construction crew, just pointing at the ground.
但后来我看到一位黑人女性停了下来，向施工队里的一名黑人男工招手，指了指地面。
Is there yellow on it? Sorry.
上面有黄色吗？抱歉。
Are you asking for a piece of it?
你是想要一块碎片吗？
Yeah. This is a huge piece. OK, I'll take this. Thank you. Oh, my god, that's heavy. [LAUGHS]
对。这是一块很大的碎片。好，我要这一块。谢谢。天哪，好沉。 [笑]
The piece she had was so big, she had to hold it with two hands. It was a piece of the letter T in the word "Matters." And the woman holding it, JC-- she's a politico, lives in DC-- she told me she was sitting at a cafe nearby when she saw someone else who had a piece and was like, oh, I want one of those.
她拿的那块太大了，得用双手捧着。那是“Matters”这个词中字母“T”的一块。那位拿着它的女士，JC——她是个政治活跃人士，住在华盛顿特区——她告诉我，她当时正坐在附近的咖啡馆里，看到别人拿了一块，就想：哦，我也想要一块。
You just walked right up. You were like, oh, can I?
你就这么直接走过去了？你问：哦，我可以拿一块吗？
Why not? I mean, he was very kind to take a break and get me a piece. And then I didn't like the first piece that he gave me.
为什么不呢？我是说，他很客气，停下来休息时给了我一块。而且我还不满意他给我的第一块。
Oh, what?
哦，什么？
I know, but I needed the yellow. I feel like the yellow was a really big--
我知道，但我需要黄色。我觉得黄色才是最关键的……
Because otherwise, it's just a piece of concrete.
因为没有黄色的话，它就只是一块普通的混凝土。
Yeah. Like, my kids aren't going to believe me if I say it's from Black Lives Matter Plaza and it's just a piece of concrete. It needed the yellow.
对。如果我告诉我的孩子们这是从“黑人的命也是命”广场拿来的，但它只是一块水泥，他们是不会相信我的。它必须得有黄色。
Oh, do you have kids right now? Oh, OK. You're talking about future kids.
哦，你现在有孩子了吗？哦，好吧。你是说未来的孩子。
Future kids. I'm thinking about them. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
未来的孩子。我在为他们考虑。对，对，对。
So I started seeing other people who were doing this, too, right? Just grabbing these pieces of the mural for future generations that did or didn't exist. There were these two women who were in town for work. One of them was scared that they were actually going to miss their flight because her friend was waiting so long for the construction workers to break off just the right piece of the mural as a souvenir.
所以我开始看到其他人也在做同样的事。为了那些尚未出生或可能根本不会出生的子孙后代，抢夺这些壁画碎片。还有两位来城里出差的女士。其中一个很担心她们会错过航班，因为她的朋友在等建筑工人敲下一块合适的壁画碎片作为纪念品。
What time is your flight? [CHUCKLING]
你们的航班几点起飞？ [轻笑]
I know. I'm heading out now.
我知道。我马上就走。
So I actually lived in DC when they first painted this street. And I got to say, at the time, when I first saw it, I totally understood how meaningful it was to some folks.
我当时住在华盛顿特区，他们刚画这条街的时候我也在。我得说，当时我第一次看到时，完全理解这对某些人来说有多大的意义。
But personally, honestly, I just kind of rolled my eyes and laughed about it with the other Black people that I knew. It just felt kind of performative, just, like, one and the same with a lot of the stuff that was happening back then, right, like Nancy Pelosi, Chuck Schumer, and co. kneeling in kente cloth in the Capitol, all those black squares people were posting.
但就我个人而言，老实说，我只是翻了个白眼，和其他认识的黑人朋友一起笑了笑。我觉得这有点做秀，就像当时发生的很多事情一样，比如南希·佩洛西、查克·舒默和他们的同事穿着肯特布在国会大厦下跪，还有人们发布的那些黑方块。
But now that I was actually here, seeing them tear this message out of the ground, it just-- I don't know-- I was just like, oh, right. It maybe didn't matter that much when it was first put in, but it definitely mattered now that it was being taken out.
但现在我身临其境，看着他们把这个信息从地上拆除，我……不知道……我就觉得，哦，对了。当它刚被铺上时可能没那么重要，但当它被拆除时，它就变得绝对重要了。
Yeah.
是的。
Across the street, I saw this older white guy who worked in urban design. He was so excited to have a piece of the thing.
在街对面，我看到一位从事城市设计的老白人。他非常兴奋能得到一块碎片。
I don't know. These letters are forever letters. It's not just concrete. It's super concrete. It's fiberglass-reinforced super concrete. So she built that to last forever.
我不知道。这些字是永恒的文字。它不仅仅是混凝土。它是超级混凝土。是玻璃纤维增强的超级混凝土。所以她建造它是为了让它永存。
For you, why is it important for you to have a piece of it?
对你来说，拥有一块它为什么这么重要？
I thought it was very divisive. I was very disappointed when the mayor did that. It was just so divisive to do that. And the rhetoric and the fighting increased after that.
我认为它非常具有分裂性。市长那样做的时候，我感到非常失望。这样做太分裂了。在那之后，言辞和冲突都加剧了。
So you're getting a piece of it kind of as a memento of the thing that you didn't like?
所以你拿走它是作为一种你不喜欢的某种事物的纪念品？
I think it's healing. To get rid of it is kind of a healing situation.
我认为这是一种治愈。摆脱它是一种治愈的情况。
OK, so talking to this guy, it hit me, he's here to mark the end of something, which I realized, oh, we all were, right? I think it was clear to absolutely everybody there on that street that one era has ended, and we're in some very new moment right now.
好吧，和这家伙谈完后，我明白了，他在这里是为了标记某个事物的终结，我意识到，哦，我们都在这里，不是吗？我想现场的每一个人都很清楚，一个时代已经结束了，我们现在正处于一个全新的时刻。
And lots of us were just trying to puzzle that out in real-time, what this means. There were these two women that I met, Saraya and Yasmeen. Saraya was on the fence about taking a piece at all. She was just sort of like, why would I want a piece of something that never felt real?
我们很多人都在试图实时解析这意味着什么。我遇到了两位女士，Saraya和Yasmeen。Saraya对是否要拿一块碎片还在犹豫。她只是觉得：为什么我要拿一件从来没觉得真实的东西的碎片呢？
But it's not felt. Black Lives Matter-- we don't matter.
但这并非虚假。“黑人的命也是命”——我们命不重要吗？
Oh, interesting.
哦，真有意思。
We don't matter. It's like, you're taking it away. It sucks.
我们命不重要。就像是，你在把它夺走。这太烂了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是的，是的，是的。
There is this thing-- sorry, sorry, sorry. There is this thing I've been thinking about, though, which is like, is this more honest, actually, that they actually are ripping this up?
有一件事——抱歉，抱歉。不过我一直在想一件事，就是这是否更诚实，他们现在真的在拆除它？
Absolutely. Oh, absolutely. This is America showing itself because it was never in you in the first place. So why am I upset that you're upending something that was never in you in the first place? I'm not saying that we shouldn't be upset. We definitely should be upset. But why are we-- we can't be upset at people that it was never in them in the first place to even care about somebody else.
绝对是。哦，绝对是。这是美国在展示它真实的面目，因为它从一开始就不在你们心里。所以我为什么要因为你们在铲除一个从始至终就不存在于你们心中的东西而难过呢？我不是说我们不应该感到难过。我们绝对应该难过。但我们为什么要……我们不能因为那些从一开始就不关心别人的人而难过。
So as I was leaving the street that day, I just felt like, oh, right. The America that I know, the one I grew up in, it leaves the sign up, right? It says it believes in all of this stuff, that all of us are equal, that we all want to live in racial harmony, whatever. And then it just kind of does what it wants.
所以那天离开街道时，我感觉……哦，对了。我所了解的那个美国，我成长的那个美国，它会把标志留在那儿，对吧？它宣称相信所有这些东西，宣称我们所有人都是平等的，我们都希望生活在种族和谐中，等等。然后它只是随心所欲地行事。
But what I saw, like the government going to these great lengths to tear up this street and to get every shred of the letters out, not even bothering to pay lip service anymore, I was like, that feels like a real shift. So yeah, that's how I ended up with this piece of concrete, which I guess is just going to live in my house forever.
但我所看到的，政府不惜一切代价拆除这条街，把每一个字母碎片都彻底清理掉，甚至连做做样子的功夫都不屑于做了，我觉得这是一种真正的转变。所以，这就是我最终得到这块混凝土的原因，我想它大概会永远待在我家里了。
It's like you have a piece of the Berlin Wall or something.
就像你有一块柏林墙的碎片一样。
You know what? It does feel like that. It feels like this thing that I want to show everybody in my life. It's like it's a part of my own personal museum.
你知道吗？确实感觉像是那样。它感觉像是我想展示给我生命中每个人看的东西。就像是我个人博物馆的一部分。
Yes, a museum. One of the things that we've been talking about here on the staff, as you know, is it feels like there are so many things happening every day since President Trump took office, like federal agencies being gutted, or a judge ordering the White House to turn some planes around and them seeming to ignore the court order, or secret war planning being done on Signal on people's phones and shared with a random reporter.
是的，博物馆。正如你所知，我们员工一直在讨论的一件事是，自从特朗普总统上任以来，每天似乎都在发生太多的事情，比如联邦机构被掏空，或者法官下令白宫让飞机掉头，而白宫似乎无视了法庭命令，或者有人在私人手机的Signal软件上进行秘密战争规划，并与一名随机的记者分享。
There is so much happening so fast, and you feel like, oh, did that really happen? And you just-- I don't know. With our staff, we've been talking about how we just want to grab a hold of these things and just put them in a place where we can look at them together, just preserve them, like a museum, a museum of now.
事情发生得太快，太多了，你可能会觉得：哦，那真的发生了吗？我不知道。我们员工一直在讨论，我们只是想抓住这些东西，把它们放在一个我们可以一起审视的地方，把它们保存下来，就像一个博物馆，一个“当下博物馆”。
I mean, this feels rude to say on the radio, but I'm going to say it, which is you know that I'm not going to give you this for your museum, right? This is mine.
我是说，在广播里说这话很粗鲁，但我还是得说，你知道我不会把这个给你存进你的博物馆的，对吧？这是我的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Fine, because today on our show, we have other historical artifacts of this exact moment we are living through. As you'll hear the people in these stories over and over, they seem sort of dumbfounded at what they're suddenly seeing and dealing with in America today. We were, too. Stay with us.
好吧，因为今天在节目中，我们还有我们所经历的这个特定时刻的其他历史文物。正如你将在这些故事中一次又一次听到的那样，人们似乎对他们突然在美国看到和处理的事情感到目瞪口呆。我们也一样。请继续收听。
It's This American Life. Today's show, "The Museum of Now." And let's take a little stroll, shall we, through the museum? Oh, watch out for the construction right there. There's some stuff. Yeah, we're just starting to build out our collection here. I guess we begin with this exhibit, a multimedia exhibit.
这是《美国生活》。今天的节目是“当下博物馆”。让我们逛一逛，好吗，参观一下博物馆？哦，当心那边的施工。有些东西。是的，我们才刚刚开始在这里构建我们的藏品。我想我们从这个展品开始，一个多媒体展品。
[SOOTHING MUSIC]
[舒缓的音乐]
This is actually the hold music that people all over the country are hearing when they try to reach the Social Security Administration. The agency sends out payments to some 70 million people every month.
这实际上是全美民众在尝试联系社会保障局时听到的等待音乐。该机构每月向约7000万人发放款项。
The agency says that it is getting way more calls than usual right now. Elon Musk and all the talk of rooting out fraud and kicking dead people off the rolls seem to be freaking out millions of senior citizens, so more of them are calling. Audits, by the way, show that lots of dead people are not getting checks. That is not a thing.
该机构称，目前收到的电话比平时多得多。埃隆·马斯克（Elon Musk）关于根除欺诈和剔除死亡名单的言论似乎让数百万老年人感到恐慌，所以更多人打了电话。顺便说一下，审计显示，许多死者并没有收到支票。根本没这回事。
Wait times were long even before this, but right now, a fourth of the callers basically get a busy signal and have to try again. If you call and you do get put on hold, there is a callback option. But one of our coworkers decided to stay on the line to see how long it would take.
在那之前等待时间就很长了，但现在，四分之一的致电者基本上会听到忙音，必须重拨。如果你打通了并且被转为等待状态，有一个回拨选项。但我们的一位同事决定在线等待，看看需要多久。
Thank you for holding. We appreciate your patience. The estimated hold time is 60 minutes.
感谢您的等待。感谢您的耐心。预计等待时间为60分钟。
[HOLD MUSIC CONTINUES]
[等待音乐持续]
Yeah, it was nowhere close to that. They finally picked up at one hour, 39 minutes.
是的，根本没那么快。他们终于在1小时39分钟后接听了。
Hi, thank you for calling.
你好，感谢您的来电。
The worker who did finally pick up the phone, I will say, was super nice, very helpful.
我得说，最后接听电话的工作人员非常好，非常有帮助。
Of course. You're welcome. Is there anything else that I could do for you at all today?
当然。不客气。今天还有什么我可以为您做的吗？
That's all.
就这些了。
All right, ma'am. Well, then you have a great rest of your day, OK?
好的，女士。祝您余下的时光愉快，好吗？
Hello. At Social Security, your satisfaction means the world to us.
您好。在社会保障局，您的满意对我们而言就是一切。
OK, next up, walk with me down the hallway here to this next exhibit. OK, stop right there. Here we have a short video. As you can see, it's playing on a loop. It was posted on X by the Secretary of Homeland Security, 8 seconds long. Security cam footage plays over and over.
好了，接下来，随我沿着走廊去下一个展品。好了，就在那儿停一下。我们有一个短视频。如你所见，它在循环播放。这是国土安全部长在X上发布的，时长8秒。监控摄像头拍下的画面一遍又一遍地播放。
And to help you understand what you're looking at, Aviva DeKornfeld has the story of the five days that led to this video for the woman who was in it. What happened in those five days caught this woman completely off guard because as far as she knew, or as we know now, what happened to her hadn't happened to anybody else at that point, just three weeks ago.
为了让你理解你所看到的内容，Aviva DeKornfeld带来了关于这段视频中的女性所经历的那五天的故事。那五天里发生的事情让这位女性完全猝不及防，因为据她所知，或者据我们现在所知，在她之前，三周前还没有人遭遇过这种事。
Day one, Thursday, 8:00 AM. Ranjani Srinivasan is not a morning person. She likes to start the day slowly, scroll on her phone in bed. She gets lots of panicked emails from her students. She's a teaching assistant. She's also a graduate student at Columbia University.
第一天，周四，上午8点。Ranjani Srinivasan不是那种早起的人。她喜欢缓慢地开始一天，在床上刷手机。她收到了很多学生发来的恐慌邮件。她是助教，也是哥伦比亚大学的研究生。
So day one, she was in bed when she saw an email, subject line, "Visa Revocation Notification." But the wording in the email was weird. It said she may be ineligible for her student visa, but also that it had been revoked. It seemed spammy.
所以第一天，她躺在床上看到一封邮件，主题是“签证吊销通知”。但这封邮件里的措辞很奇怪。它说她可能没有资格获得学生签证，但也说签证已被吊销。这看起来像垃圾邮件。
Just because Columbia sometimes does phishing trainings, so I actually thought that this might be one of those. It just seemed so strange. I took a screenshot and actually put it in my department WhatsApp group with all the other PhDs asking, did you guys get this?
因为哥伦比亚大学有时会进行网络钓鱼培训，所以我真的以为这可能是其中之一。它看起来太奇怪了。我截了图，并发到了我们部门的WhatsApp小组里，问其他博士生有没有收到。
What did people respond?
大家的反应是什么？
They were like, oh, my god, what the hell is this? And then they told me that they hadn't got this email.
他们说：天哪，这到底是什么鬼？然后他们告诉我，他们没收到这封邮件。
Ranjani thought, hmm, OK, it seems to be real. But she's lived here a long time, nine years, and she's had a lot of visas. Things happen sometimes. So she emails the International Students and Scholars' Office-- they've helped her out with the visa stuff before-- and also the Dean of Student Affairs, and asked for help straightening this out.
Ranjani想：嗯，好吧，看来是真的。但她在这里住很长时间了，九年了，拿过很多次签证。有时会出点状况。所以她给国际学生和学者办公室发了邮件——他们以前帮她处理过签证问题——也给学生事务院长发了邮件，寻求帮助理清此事。
Then she grabs her stuff and heads to the office she shares with the other PhDs, where she spends most of her time, to get some grading done. She had 60 student sketchbooks she needed to get through before Monday. That evening, she hears back from the International Students Office, who CC's the Dean of Student Affairs and tells her--
然后她拿上东西，前往她与其他博士生共享的办公室，她大部分时间都在那儿批改作业。在周一之前，她有60本学生的写生簿要处理。那天晚上，她收到了国际学生办公室的回信，他们抄送了学生事务院长，并告诉她——
Don't worry. This sometimes happens. Just book an online advising session through our system, and just don't leave the country. Otherwise, you are in legal status. You can go to work. You can grade your students' work, stuff like that. And that was one of the big questions in my head, right? So I was sort of going back and forth during the time, waiting for her reply, thinking whether I should be grading or should I not be grading.
不用担心。这种情况有时会发生。只需通过我们的系统预订一个在线咨询会话即可，而且不要离开这个国家。除此之外，你的法律状态没问题。你可以去工作。你可以批改学生作业之类的。那是我脑子里的一大疑问，对吧？所以我当时在等待她回复的时候有点左右为难，在想我是该改作业还是不该改。
Oh, so you were trying to distract yourself by grading papers, but then you're like, is this breaking the law itself?
哦，所以你想通过批改作业来分散注意力，但后来又想：这本身是不是违法？
Yes, exactly. But it wasn't. So I was told in writing that I was allowed to just go about my normal life. I don't need to worry. This is all being treated as very run-of-the-mill. And the tone from Columbia is that this happens to many students. It's not a rare thing.
是的，正是如此。但事实并非如此。所以我被书面告知我可以继续正常生活。我不必担心。这一切都被视为非常普通的常规处理。哥伦比亚大学的口吻是，这种情况发生在许多学生身上。这不是什么罕见的事情。
They tell her the next available appointment is in five days. Five days felt like too long to wait. The college was telling her that this would all get sorted out easily, but Ranjani has always been fastidious about her paperwork. She has an encrypted folder on her computer for all things visa-related.
他们告诉她下一次预约在五天后。五天感觉太长了。学院告诉她这一切都可以轻松解决，但Ranjani一直对文书工作非常细致。她的电脑里有一个加密文件夹，存放着所有与签证相关的文件。
She's been in the US since 2016 and knows almost all her entry and exit dates off the top of her head. She doesn't like loose ends, and she didn't like the idea of waiting five days. So she gets them to change the appointment to the next day.
她自2016年以来一直住在美国，几乎能脱口而出她所有的入境和出境日期。她不喜欢遗留任何问题，也不喜欢等待五天。所以她让他们把预约时间改到了第二天。
Ranjani is from Chennai, in the south of India. And in 2016, she was awarded a Fulbright to get a master's in design at Harvard. And she was very excited to go to an American university.
Ranjani来自印度南部的金奈。2016年，她获得了一项富布赖特奖学金，去哈佛大学攻读设计硕士学位。她对去美国大学深造感到非常兴奋。
The US scholarship is really robust. There's a great intellectual culture of inquiry. A lot of the people I had read, or like my intellectual heroes, went to many of these universities-- David Harvey. He's an economic geographer. And Ambedkar, who is the architect of the Indian constitution, actually studied at Columbia. So I was super excited to see the US and take part in this culture of inquiry.
美国的奖学金制度非常健全。那里有着伟大的探究文化。我读过的很多作者，或者说我的知识英雄，都去过这些大学——比如大卫·哈维（David Harvey）。他是一位经济地理学家。还有印度宪法的设计师安贝德卡尔（Ambedkar），实际上就在哥伦比亚大学学习过。所以我超级兴奋能看到美国并参与到这种探究文化中。
She graduated with a master's from Harvard and then followed her intellectual hero to Columbia to get a PhD in urban planning. Her work focuses on the way that urbanization impacts the labor force. She often went back to India to do fieldwork.
她从哈佛硕士毕业，然后跟随她的知识英雄来到哥伦比亚大学攻读城市规划博士学位。她的研究重点是城市化如何影响劳动力。她经常回印度进行实地考察。
But she settled happily in her life on campus. She's made lots of friends, including her roommate, another PhD student. The university randomly paired them together years ago, and they've since become close. Every year, the two of them take a family portrait with Ranjani's cat, Cricket, and send it around as a Christmas card.
但她在校园里快乐地安顿了下来。她交了很多朋友，包括她的室友，另一位博士生。几年前大学随机把她们分到一起，从此她们变得亲密无间。每年，两人都会和Ranjani的猫Cricket一起拍张全家福，作为圣诞贺卡发给大家。
Day two, Friday, 10:30 AM. Ranjani is in her bedroom. She hops on a Zoom call for her appointment with the International Students Office advisor, and starts explaining the situation with the weird email. Meanwhile, Ranjani's roommate is in the other room braiding her hair, getting ready for the day. Here's her roommate. To protect her privacy, we're not naming her.
第二天，周五，上午10:30。Ranjani在卧室里。她参加了与国际学生办公室顾问的Zoom会议，开始解释关于那封奇怪邮件的情况。与此同时，Ranjani的室友正在另一个房间编头发，准备出门。这是她的室友。为了保护隐私，我们不提她的名字。
And suddenly I hear this bang, bang, bang, bang, which it's that particular tone-- it's a scary knock. And so I step up-- and again, half of my hair is unbraided, half of it's braided. The cat's confused, I'm confused.
突然我听到砰、砰、砰、砰的声音，那是一种特定的语调——一种可怕的敲门声。所以我走过去——再一次，我的头发编了一半，没编一半。猫很困惑，我也很困惑。
I go to the door, and I go, who is it? Someone yells back, police! And I go, OK, whoa. My heart's beating fast. And I just know that I don't want to open the door because, one, anyone can yell, police. Two, I'm in my bathrobe. And so any kind of armed men is not walking into my apartment right now.
我走到门口，喊道：是谁？有人大喊：警察！我喊道：好吧，哇。我的心跳加速。我只是知道我不想开门，因为第一，任何人都可以冒充警察大喊。第二，我穿着浴袍。所以任何武装人员现在都别想走进我的公寓。
Ranjani, in her bedroom, she doesn't hear the knock. She couldn't hear it over the reassurances from the advisor from the International Students Office.
卧室里的Ranjani没听到敲门声。她在Zoom上顾问的安抚声中没听见。
They're basically saying stuff like, don't worry. This sometimes happens. So then I clarify that I can actually grade my students' work, which is forefront in my mind right now.
他们基本上在说：别担心。这种情况有时会发生。所以我澄清说我实际上可以批改学生作业，这在当时是我脑子里最重要的事情。
The scary knocker knocks again. Ranjani's roommate told me she's a citizen and a woman of color who grew up poor, who's had a lot of interactions with the police, none of which she would describe as positive. But she knows what to do. She calls from inside the apartment, what is this about?
那可怕的敲门声再次响起。Ranjani的室友告诉我，她是一名公民，一位在贫困中长大的有色人种女性，有过很多与警察打交道的经历，她一点也不觉得那些经历积极。但她知道该做什么。她在公寓里大声问道：这是怎么回事？
They start reeling off information about Ranjani in a very sort of good cop kind of way. They're like, oh, we know that her visa was canceled. We're the only people you can turn to. We just want to talk to you. We just have some questions. And I'm sort of there just like, who's we?
他们开始以一种类似“好警察”的口吻滔滔不绝地讲述有关Ranjani的信息。他们说：哦，我们知道她的签证被取消了。我们是你唯一可以求助的人。我们只想和你谈谈。我们只是有些问题。我当时就在想：我们是谁？
And I can't see through-- I can't see anyone through my peephole. And so the voice starts talking about really intimate details of Ranjani's visa and immigration status. And I stop him and I go, wait, do you have a warrant? He doesn't respond to that. And I sort of just keep asking, what is this about?
我从猫眼里看不见任何人。那声音开始谈论Ranjani签证和移民身份中非常私密的细节。我打断他：等等，你有搜查令吗？他没回答。我只是不断地问：这到底是关于什么的？
She goes to tell Ranjani what's happening.
她去告诉Ranjani正在发生什么。
I guess I wasn't paying attention to the door. I was focused on the Zoom conversation. So sometime midway through the conversation, through the door, she turns and tells me, ICE is at the door.
我想我当时没注意门口。我专注于Zoom对话。所以谈话进行到一半时，她在门那边转身告诉我：移民局（ICE）在门口。
What do you think when you hear that?
你听到那个时怎么想的？
I'm freaking out, just freaking out. I just start shivering and shaking because I'm still on Zoom with my advisor, who, till the last second, was saying, you're fine, you can go out and teach your students.
我吓坏了，简直吓坏了。我开始发抖，因为我还在Zoom上和我的顾问通话，她直到最后一秒还在说：你没事，你可以出去给学生上课。
But I tell the advisor that ICE is at my door. Tell me what to do. And you can see the advisor's eyes kind of become wide. She says, OK, just give me a second. She mutes herself, and she's frantically talking to people, like higher ups.
但我告诉顾问ICE在门口。告诉我该怎么做。你可以看到顾问的眼睛睁得很大。她说：好的，给我一秒钟。她把自己静音了，疯狂地和高层交流。
The advisor eventually unmutes, looking relaxed again. And she tells Ranjani that she's safe. Just don't open the door for ICE. And then she gives her a list of immigration lawyers to contact.
顾问最终取消了静音，看起来又放松了。她告诉Ranjani她是安全的。只需别给ICE开门。然后她给了她一份移民律师名单供她联系。
And I was like, won't Columbia have a lawyer? Won't they be negotiating with ICE on my behalf? Why am I on my own? And she's like, oh, that's not something that happens. You shouldn't have any issues. And then I just told her that I don't really trust Columbia at this point. And then she says, oh, but do you trust me?
我说：哥伦比亚大学没有律师吗？他们不会代表我与ICE谈判吗？为什么我只能孤立无援？她说：哦，那是不会发生的事情。你应该不会有任何问题。然后我告诉她，此时我已经不太相信哥伦比亚大学了。她说：哦，那你信任我吗？
What'd you say?
你说了什么？
I mean, I just told her I don't know you.
我是说，我只是告诉她我不认识你。
What'd she say to that?
她说了什么？
She just was like, just call the lawyers, and don't open the door.
她只是说：去联系律师，别开门。
They don't open the door, and the ICE officers eventually leave. Ranjani has had enough experience as an immigrant in this country to know that ICE is not supposed to show up at your door a day after your visa is revoked. This is not the way things typically work.
她们没开门，ICE的官员最终离开了。Ranjani作为这个国家的移民，经历过足够多的事情，知道ICE不应该在签证吊销后的第二天就出现在你门口。事情通常不是这样运作的。
How it normally goes, you're granted a student visa, and the visa is the thing that allows you to enter the country. And once you're here, if you're a student, you can legally stay as long as you're enrolled in school, even if your visa is revoked. But if you stop attending school, then you have to leave the country.
通常情况下，你获得学生签证，签证是让你进入这个国家的凭证。一旦你到了这里，如果你是学生，只要你注册了学校，即使签证被吊销，你也可以合法逗留。但如果你停止上学，那就必须离开该国。
This is what Ranjani was turning over in her head with ICE at the door. She still had her status as a student. She was still enrolled at Columbia. The advisor woman from Columbia on Zoom was telling her there should be no issue. But there was one, at her door. Ranjani thought, I have to get out of here. I need to hide.
这就是Ranjani在ICE敲门时脑子里反复盘算的事情。她依然拥有学生身份。她仍然在哥伦比亚大学注册。Zoom上的哥伦比亚大学顾问告诉她应该没问题。但在她的门口却有问题。Ranjani心想：我必须离开这里。我需要躲起来。
I'm absolutely paralyzed with fear. I'm not able to think straight. I just thought that if I go somewhere else for a bit, I will feel a little safer, and things will hopefully blow over. I mean, I fully intended to return to my apartment. So I literally just take a couple of pairs of clothes and a shower gel and a loofah. So that's all I literally had on me.
我完全被恐惧瘫痪了。我无法正常思考。我只是觉得如果我去别处待一会儿，我会感觉稍微安全一点，事情希望能够平息。我是说，我完全打算回我的公寓。所以我 literally 只拿了几套衣服、沐浴露和丝瓜络。这就是我身上仅有的东西。
Wow, the loofah made the cut.
哇，丝瓜络竟然入选了。
[CHUCKLES] Yeah. Well, you need something to keep your spirits up.
[轻笑] 是啊。嗯，你得有东西来振奋精神。
Ranjani moves to her friend's apartment. She and her roommate decide that it's safer if her roommate doesn't know where she's going so that should ICE come back, she can truthfully say she doesn't know where Ranjani is.
Ranjani搬到了朋友的公寓。她和室友决定，如果室友不知道她去哪儿会更安全，这样如果ICE回来，她可以如实说不知道Ranjani在哪里。
But a few of Ranjani's other friends gather at the new location, and everyone starts calling immigration lawyers to try and figure out what to do. Meanwhile, the Dean of Student Affairs, who Ranjani first reached out to when she got the suspicious email from the consulate, calls her and says--
但Ranjani的其他几个朋友聚集在新地点，大家都开始联系移民律师试图弄清楚该做什么。与此同时，Ranjani在收到领事馆那封可疑邮件时最初联系的学生事务院长给她打电话说——
Oh, I heard about ICE coming to your door. I'm so sorry. Let me know if I can do anything for you. And then I basically tell her, I'm really scared. Why are they here? I don't understand. Can you please talk to ISO, the International Students Office? And then they tell me, oh, I will do that. But it seems that even the International Students Office or Columbia, nobody seems to be in control.
哦，我听说ICE去你家了。我很抱歉。如果我能为你做点什么请告诉我。然后我基本上告诉她：我很害怕。他们为什么在这儿？我不明白。你能和ISO（国际学生办公室）谈谈吗？他们告诉我说：哦，我会做的。但似乎即使是国际学生办公室或哥伦比亚大学，也没人能掌控局面。
Whoa.
哇。
Yeah. I'm still calling lawyers. I'm going through all my legal options. Again, we don't know why this is happening, right? Because I'm still in legal status. It's just my visa that's been revoked. So under any circumstance, I legally can be in the country. I can legally be working. Everything is fine.
是的。我还在联系律师。我正在审查我所有的法律选项。再一次，我们不知道为什么会发生这种情况，对吧？因为我仍然处于合法的身份状态。只是我的签证被吊销了。所以无论在任何情况下，我都在法律上可以在这个国家逗留。我可以在法律上工作。一切都好。
Because the way it works is that the visa is just like a key to let you in and out. But your legal status is like a rental agreement of your house, you know? You have the right to be there, even if you lose the key.
因为它的运作方式是，签证就像让你进出的钥匙。但你的合法身份就像你房子的租赁协议，你知道吗？即使钥匙丢了，你也有权留在那里。
She wracks her brain for mistakes she might have made, looks back through all her immigration records, but she can't find anything.
她费尽心思去想自己可能犯的错误，回顾了所有的移民记录，但找不到任何问题。
Day three, Saturday, 6:20 PM. Ranjani is at her friend's place when her roommate calls her. She tells Ranjani ICE came back to the apartment. They didn't have a warrant, but they talked through the door. Her roommate recorded it.
第三天，周六，下午6:20。Ranjani在朋友家时，室友给她打电话。她说ICE又回到了公寓。他们没有搜查令，但他们在门外谈话。她的室友录了音。
Hey, Ranjani if this is you, listen. You don't have to answer any questions, OK? But let me just speak. We were here yesterday. We're here today. We're going to be here tonight, tomorrow. You're probably scared. If you are, I get it. The reality is your visa was revoked, OK? You are now amenable to removal proceedings.
嘿，Ranjani，如果是你，听着。你不用回答任何问题，好吗？但让我把话说完。我们昨天在这儿。我们今天在这儿。我们今晚、明天还会在这儿。你可能很害怕。如果是这样，我明白。现实情况是你的签证被吊销了，好吗？你现在适用驱逐程序。
Ranjani realizes the situation is not going to go away. The email was not spam, ICE showing up at her apartment not a fluke. She was being targeted. She'd never heard of this happening to anyone else. The rules, how things normally work, that was changing. But she didn't know it yet.
Ranjani意识到这种情况不会消失。那封邮件不是垃圾邮件，ICE出现在她公寓也不是偶然。她成了被针对的目标。她从没听说过这种情况发生在别人身上。规则，事物通常的运作方式，正在改变。但她当时还不知道。
And then the same night her roommate tells her that ICE came back, ICE showed up at the apartment of another student, a Columbia graduate student named Mahmoud Khalil, who had just finished his degree in December. Mahmoud was coming home with his wife that night, unlocking his apartment door, when ICE appeared and detained him, took him away to a detention center in Louisiana. Mahmoud has a green card. His wife, Noor, is a citizen.
就在室友告诉她ICE回来的当天晚上，ICE出现在了另一名学生——哥伦比亚大学研究生Mahmoud Khalil——的公寓，他刚在12月完成学业。Mahmoud那天晚上和妻子回家，正打开公寓门时，ICE出现并拘留了他，把他带到了路易斯安那州的一处拘留中心。Mahmoud有绿卡。他的妻子Noor是公民。
I remember reading about it in the paper, and I was extremely scared. If my flatmate had not been there, that would have been me. Again, I have no stranger danger. I would have just opened the door, and they would have detained me.
我记得在报纸上读到过，我极其害怕。如果我的室友当时不在那儿，那个人就是我了。再一次，我没有防人之心。我会直接开门，他们就会拘留我。
I think the idea of Mahmoud's being in Louisiana and not able to speak to his lawyers scared me greatly. It was beyond my imagination. I mean, during this entire experience, I just felt that this was sort of a disembodied view of what was happening. It didn't seem real that this would happen to any of us. Yeah.
我想Mahmoud在路易斯安那州无法与律师交谈的想法让我非常害怕。这超出了我的想象。我是说，在整个经历中，我只是觉得这是一个关于正在发生什么事情的脱节视角。这看起来不真实，这种事竟然会发生在我们任何人身上。是的。
It felt fever dream-ish.
感觉就像一场狂热的梦。
Yeah. No, and I couldn't sleep, I couldn't eat. I was shaking all the time. And most of my friends will tell you, I'm a very calm person. I'm really good in a crisis. But this was just an unprecedented situation. Everything that's happened has been outside the realm of possibility, in my head. So I had to prepare as if the worst might happen and act in those ways.
是的。不，我无法入睡，无法进食。我一直在发抖。我大多数朋友都会告诉你，我是个非常冷静的人。我在危机中表现很好。但这是一个史无前例的情况。我脑子里发生的一切都超出了可能性的范围。所以我必须做好最坏的打算并采取相应的行动。
Ranjani did not know Mahmoud Khalil. She learned he was a leader of the pro-Palestine protests after he'd been detained. And here, a new thought occurs to her. She had liked some pro-Palestine posts on social media. She'd also signed a few open letters and gone to a couple peaceful protests.
Ranjani不认识Mahmoud Khalil。她了解到他是被拘留后的亲巴勒斯坦抗议活动的领导人。就在这时，一个新的想法浮现在她脑海中。她曾在社交媒体上点赞过一些支持巴勒斯坦的帖子。她还签署了几封公开信，并参加过几次和平抗议。
And one night, coming home from a PhD picnic, she says she accidentally ran into a big protest on campus. It was chaotic. She says she got swept up by police officers, along with a bunch of other people. She received two summonses-- for blocking a sidewalk and refusing to disperse-- but they were both dismissed.
有一天晚上，从博士生的野餐活动回家时，她说她偶然撞见了一场校园里的大型抗议。场面混乱。她说她和其他一群人一起被警察带走了。她收到了两份传票——因为阻碍人行道和拒绝散开——但都被驳回了。
And now, Ranjani wondered, is that what all this is about? It seemed impossible she'd be targeted so personally for that. But what just happened to Mahmoud Khalil, that seemed impossible, too.
现在，Ranjani感到困惑：这就是这一切的原因吗？因为这样而被如此个人化地针对似乎是不可能的。但刚刚发生在Mahmoud Khalil身上的事，似乎也是不可能的。
Day four, Sunday, 5:00 PM. Ranjani gets an email from Columbia saying that the Department of Homeland Security had now terminated her legal status, and the university was dis-enrolling her. She was no longer a student, no longer a teaching assistant.
第四天，周日，下午5点。Ranjani收到哥伦比亚大学的一封邮件，称国土安全部现在已经终止了她的合法身份，大学正在将她除名。她不再是学生，不再是助教。
I lost my legal status, I lost my worker status, and I also lost my housing. So I was really unhappy. And then when I got this email, actually, the Dean of Student Affairs in my school came into my building and was ringing the doorbell, trying to find out whether I'd received the email telling me to vacate and getting a confirmation that I've received the email and I'm going to leave the apartment.
我失去了合法身份，失去了工作身份，也失去了住房。所以我非常不开心。然后当我收到这封邮件时，我学校的学生事务院长实际上来到了我的楼里，正在按门铃，试图查明我是否收到了告诉我要搬走的邮件，并确认我收到了这封邮件且准备离开公寓。
So at that point, I knew Columbia was either complicit or working with law enforcement. I just felt completely betrayed because I don't have a disciplinary record. I have a perfect GPA. I haven't done anything. And the fact that I just felt like a sacrifice, almost, it just feels like the institution doesn't really care.
所以在那一点上，我知道哥伦比亚大学要么是同谋，要么是在与执法部门合作。我感到彻底的背叛，因为我没有违纪记录。我有完美的GPA。我什么都没做。而且我只是觉得像个牺牲品，几乎就是觉得学校并不真正在乎。
Columbia University wouldn't speak to Ranjani's case in particular, but they sent us a statement that says, the university follows the law and, quote, "takes great care to ensure our legal compliance with all applicable rules and obligations so that our students can participate in the federal Student and Exchange Visitor Program."
哥伦比亚大学不对Ranjani的案件发表具体评论，但他们给我们发了一份声明，说大学遵守法律，并称“非常谨慎地确保我们对所有适用的规则和义务的法律遵从，以便我们的学生能够参与联邦学生和交流访问者项目。”
Day five, Ranjani's lawyers told her she could fight this, but she'd likely be detained for some amount of time, no idea how long, though, as it would be a federal case, it would probably be at least a year while it wound its way through the courts. The only way to avoid detention, her lawyers told her, was voluntary departure. Ranjani thought, I have some friends and relatives in Canada. That's close by.
第五天，Ranjani的律师告诉她，她可以抗争，但可能会被拘留一段时间，不知道多久，因为这是联邦案件，在法院审理期间可能至少需要一年。律师告诉她，避免拘留的唯一方法是自愿离开。Ranjani心想：我在加拿大有一些朋友和亲戚。那很近。
It was quite a quick decision. I bought my plane ticket on Tuesday, and I left on Tuesday. I think just the idea of detention, at some level, I was like, is even a PhD worth spending several years in jail? Or we don't know how long. We don't know what charges.
这是一个相当快的决定。我周二买了机票，周二就离开了。我想只是拘留的想法，在某种程度上，我当时想，即使是博士学位值得花几年时间蹲监狱吗？或者我们不知道多久。我们不知道什么指控。
There's so many unknowns. My lawyers kept telling me all this is unprecedented territory. And I just thought the risks were too high. I don't know. I just spent so many days in panic. And I'm extremely, extremely fearful of detention. I'm very claustrophobic.
有太多的未知数。我的律师一直告诉我这一切都是史无前例的领域。我只是觉得风险太高了。我不知道。我只是在恐慌中度过了太多天。我对拘留感到非常、非常恐惧。我患有幽闭恐惧症。
And I don't think I would have been able to survive in a cell for years. Or I don't even know how long this is going to take, right? So there are just too many unknowns. Also, the likelihood of winning these lawsuits is also not that high, was also what I gathered. So yeah, I guess my freedom was more important.
我不认为我能在牢房里生存几年。或者我甚至不知道这需要多久，对吧？所以未知数太多了。而且，赢得这些诉讼的可能性也不是很高，这也是我搜集到的信息。所以是的，我想我的自由更重要。
How American.
真够“美国”的。
Those fears Ranjani had about what might have happened if she had stayed, well, two days after she left, at 9:40 PM--
Ranjani担心的如果她留下会发生什么，嗯，在她离开两天后，晚上9:40——
I, again, get the knock, but the knock doesn't stop.
我又听到了敲门声，但敲门声没停。
This is Ranjani's roommate again. She grabs her phone to start recording.
这是Ranjani的室友。她抓起手机开始录音。
Whereas before, it was maybe 20 seconds of knocking, this time, it's just knock, knock, knock, knock, knock, knock, knock, in that same aggressive, sort of authoritative way for probably three minutes.
如果说之前是大约20秒的敲门声，这一次，就是敲、敲、敲、敲、敲、敲、敲，以同样挑衅的、某种权威的方式敲了大概三分钟。
This time, it's also different because they have Campus Safety with them, the Columbia campus police.
这次也不同，因为他们带了校园安全部门的人，即哥伦比亚大学校园警察。
So someone calls through the door, hey, you got to open the door. And I hear a key in my lock.
所以有人在门外喊：嘿，你得开门。我听到锁里有钥匙的声音。
[DOOR UNLOCKING]
[门锁打开声]
And at that point, I hop up. I am in full "defend my home" mode. They go, it's the police! We're coming in. We have a warrant. And they're opening the door. So all I hear is, hands up, hands up.
在那一点上，我跳了起来。我完全处于“保卫我的家”模式。他们喊：是警察！我们要进来了。我们有搜查令。他们正在开门。所以我听到的一切就是：举起手来，举起手来。
Police. Let me see your hands. Let me see your hands.
警察。让我看到你的手。让我看到你的手。
Hands are up. Hands are up.
手举起来了。手举起来了。
OK, turn around. Where is your location?
好了，转过去。你的位置在哪里？
I don't understand the question.
我不明白这个问题。
Where do you reside in this apartment?
你住在这个公寓的哪个房间？
I reside in the door on the right.
我住在右边的房间。
Door on the right? OK, go over there.
右边的房间？好的，去那边。
I have a cat in the living room. Please do not touch her.
客厅里有只猫。请不要碰她。
OK, do you want to bring her in your room?
好的，你想把她带进你的房间吗？
Yes, I would.
是的，我想。
OK, go ahead.
好的，去吧。
And what is your name?
你叫什么名字？
Is your roommate here?
你的室友在这儿吗？
No one is here except for me and my cat.
除了我和我的猫，没人在这儿。
OK.
好的。
What is your name?
你叫什么名字？
Can you please-- can you please get that? We can talk at the end.
你能——你能拿到那个吗？我们可以最后再谈。
Let me get the cat [INAUDIBLE].
让我把猫抓来 [听不清]。
First, we need to clear this room, make sure there's nothing dangerous or anything in here. Is there any weapons in the apartment?
首先，我们需要清理这个房间，确保里面没有什么危险的东西。公寓里有武器吗？
There are no weapons in the apartment.
公寓里没有武器。
Where does your roommate reside?
你的室友住哪儿？
I'm not-- My roommate's legal address is this apartment.
我不——我室友的法律地址是这个公寓。
OK, thank you.
好的，谢谢。
I'm not sure where they are.
我不确定他们在哪儿。
OK.
好的。
And my cat's terrified on the couch. I grab her up. She's freaking out, as cats do.
我的猫在沙发上吓坏了。我抓起她。她像猫一样惊慌失措。
Come here. Come here, sweetie. Come here, sweetie.
过来，过来，亲爱的。过来，亲爱的。
There's a guy in a shirt and a bulletproof vest clearing through the doors. He's opening, bang, opening, bang, opening, bang, doors, going through everything, opening the closets, opening all of this stuff.
有一个穿着衬衫和防弹背心的人正在搜查房间。他在开门，砰，开门，砰，开门，砰，搜查所有东西，打开衣柜，打开所有的东西。
The ICE officers are all wearing masks with their comically large bulletproof vests. The Campus Safety guy, in his Columbia University lanyard, is just kind of standing around. If there is any question of Columbia working with ICE, it seems like it's answered here. Eventually, they all leave.
ICE的官员都戴着面具，穿着滑稽的大号防弹背心。那个戴着哥伦比亚大学挂绳的校园安全员只是站在旁边。如果说有什么关于哥伦比亚大学与ICE合作的疑问，这里似乎给出了答案。最终，他们都离开了。
Here's your warrant. This is the return saying we didn't take anything.
这是你的搜查令。这是说我们没带走任何东西的回执。
And where's the judge's signature?
法官的签名在哪里？
Right there.
就在那儿。
US magistrate judge, OK.
美国治安法官，好的。
There you go. Thank you. Have a nice day.
给你。谢谢。祝你有美好的一天。
I will not say the same for you.
我对你可说不出这话。
Ranjani has been in Canada for just over two weeks now. Columbia still hasn't reached out since ICE raided her apartment. She has no idea whether she'll be able to finish the degree she was a few months from completing, the degree she's worked towards for the better part of a decade.
Ranjani在加拿大待了两个多星期了。自从ICE突袭她公寓以来，哥伦比亚大学还没联系过她。她不知道她是否还能完成那个她离毕业只差几个月的学位，那个她为了之付出了近十年的努力的学位。
And Ranjani is only now starting to get some information about what the government says she did wrong. The Department of Homeland Security has said that she failed to disclose the two summonses she received last spring, when she applied to renew her visa. Ranjani says that was a mistake. She didn't think to include them because they'd been dismissed.
而且Ranjani现在才开始获得一些关于政府说她做错了什么的信息。国土安全部表示，她在申请续签签证时未能披露她收到的那两份传票。Ranjani说那是个错误。她没想到要把它们包含进去，因为它们已经被驳回了。
And even though she's left the country, the government has not let up. She was eating lunch the other day when she got a message from her union rep saying, there's a video of you circulating online, tweeted out by the head of DHS, Kristi Noem. This is the video I thought was worthy of adding to our Museum of Now, 8 seconds of grainy security footage from LaGuardia Airport. In it, Ranjani is kind of jog-walking through the airport, pulling her carry-on bag behind her.
即使她离开了该国，政府也没有放松。她前几天正在吃午饭，收到了工会代表发来的信息：网上流传着一段关于你的视频，由DHS负责人克里斯蒂·诺姆（Kristi Noem）发推特分享。这就是我认为值得加入我们的“当下博物馆”的视频，8秒钟来自拉瓜迪亚机场的模糊监控录像。在视频中，Ranjani在机场里有点像慢跑一样走着，后面拖着她的行李箱。
Alongside the video, Kristi Noem wrote, "It is a privilege to be granted a visa to live and study in the United States of America. When you advocate for violence and terrorism, that privilege should be revoked, and you should not be in this country." She celebrated Ranjani's, quote unquote, "self-deportation," as if running to safety was some kind of admission of guilt.
伴随着视频，克里斯蒂·诺姆写道：“能够获得签证在美国生活和学习是一种特权。当你鼓吹暴力和恐怖主义时，这种特权就应该被撤销，你不应该待在这个国家。”她庆祝了Ranjani所谓的“自我遣返”，仿佛逃向安全是一种承认罪行。
Yeah, I was sort of shocked seeing it on Twitter, because I actually didn't know who Kristi Noem was also, so I didn't really know what was the context of this video.
是的，我在推特上看到时感到有些震惊，因为我实际上不知道克里斯蒂·诺姆是谁，所以我真的不知道这段视频的背景是什么。
So you're like, why is this random lady tweeting a video of me?
所以你在想：为什么这个随机的女人要推特转发我的视频？
A little bit yes.
有点是的。
What was it like for you to watch the video?
看这段视频对你来说是什么感觉？
Oh, I was like, why am I walking so funny? I guess that was the first reaction mentally, but--
哦，我当时想：为什么我走得这么搞笑？我想那是我精神上的第一反应，但是——
You are kind of rushing in the video.
视频里的你确实有点匆忙。
Yeah, so basically, what happened was, I was really hungry, and I stopped for a bite. And I kind of lost track of time.
是的，基本上发生了什么事是，我真的很饿，停下来吃了点东西。我有点记错时间了。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
I thought I was late for the flight.
我以为我误了航班。
It's like the perfect 5-second snapshot to be like, look, she's running away. But actually, the reason you're walking quickly is utterly mundane.
这就像是完美的5秒钟快照，像是说：看，她在逃跑。但实际上，你走得快的原因完全是平凡琐事。
Yeah, I mean, you see such people every day in airports, right? So for her to tweet this, it seemed a little strange.
是的，我是说，你在机场每天都能看到这样的人，对吧？所以她发这条推文，看起来有点奇怪。
The day DHS released the video, they also put out a press release saying that Ranjani was involved in activities supporting Hamas, a terrorist organization. Ranjani says that's absurd, that she never advocated for violence in any form, and that she was engaged in peaceful protest. I reached out to DHS. They didn't respond to our questions.
DHS发布视频的那天，他们还发布了一份新闻稿，称Ranjani参与了支持哈马斯这一恐怖组织的活动。Ranjani说这很荒谬，她从不以任何形式鼓吹暴力，她从事的是和平抗议。我联系了DHS。他们没有回复我们的问题。
Ranjani has been personally targeted by one of the world's superpowers, a fact that feels so preposterous and surreal, it's impossible for her to wrap her head around, even now. So instead, she finds that her mind keeps landing on more familiar terrain. There's an image that keeps coming back to her. It's from day one, Thursday, March 6, the day she got that first spammy-seeming email.
Ranjani被世界超级大国之一个人化地针对，这个事实听起来如此荒谬和超现实，即使到现在她也无法理解。所以相反，她发现自己的思绪总是在更熟悉的领域徘徊。有一个画面总是在她脑海中挥之不去。那是第一天，3月6日星期四，她收到那第一封看起来像垃圾邮件的那一天。
I remember sitting in the PhD office and grading and chatting with my other friends in there. I guess that's the thought that keeps looping in my head. I'm just like, will I ever be able to do this again?
我记得坐在博士办公室里批改作业，和那里的其他朋友聊天。我想这就是那个在我脑海中不断循环的想法。我只是在想：我还能再做这件事吗？
Because that was the last normal thing that you'd done.
因为那是你做过的最后一件正常的事情。
Yeah, exactly. The sequence of events was just so far out, the level of escalation. Like, it has shaken my sense of reality completely.
是的，正是如此。这一系列事件发生的太离谱了，升级的程度。它彻底动摇了我的现实感。
Ranjani contains a kind of contradiction. She's someone who is deeply committed to the rules, and she tried to operate within those rules. Even after she left the country, she couldn't help but think, but I was in compliance. But also, some part of her sensed the rules had changed.
Ranjani包含了一种矛盾。她是一个深信规则的人，并试图在这些规则内运作。即使在她离开该国后，她也忍不住想：但我确实遵守了规定。但同时，她的一部分也感觉到规则已经变了。
Aviva DeKornfeld is a producer on our show.
Aviva DeKornfeld是我们节目的制作人。
Since Ranjani left the country, more students and faculty have been detained or deported by ICE. Secretary of State Marco Rubio was asked at a press conference just how many foreign students have had their visas revoked. He said at least 300.
自从Ranjani离开该国后，更多的学生和教职员工被ICE拘留或驱逐。国务卿马可·卢比奥（Marco Rubio）在新闻发布会上被问及有多少外国学生被吊销了签证。他说至少300个。
Maybe more than 300 at this point. We do it every day. Every time I find one of these lunatics, I take away their visa. We're looking every day.
目前可能不止300个。我们每天都在做。每次我发现这些疯子中的一个，我就拿走他们的签证。我们每天都在寻找。
Coming up, somebody talks to a Trump administration official and holds their feet to the fire about incorrect facts that they're basing policy on in a way I just have never heard, not from reporters, not from other politicians, not from anybody. This official is simply not allowed to walk away from the conversation. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，有人与特朗普政府的一名官员谈话，并针对他们制定政策所基于的不正确事实对他们施压，这种方式我闻所未闻，无论是记者、其他政客，还是任何人。这位官员根本无法回避这场对话。这将在芝加哥公共广播电台的节目中一分钟后播出，我们的节目将继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Museum of Now." So many things around us seem to be changing so quickly since President Trump took office that it is hard to keep track. We thought it would be a good idea to create this museum where we could all pause for a minute, consider what is in front of us, what is happening.
这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目，“当下博物馆”。自特朗普总统上任以来，我们周围似乎有太多事情发生得如此之快，以至于很难跟踪。我们认为创建一个博物馆是个好主意，我们可以在这里停下一分钟，审视我们面前的事物，正在发生的事情。
And let's just head down the hallway here, OK, past the big map of the Gulf of America, and then past the pictures of President Trump on the lawn of the White House with a big, red Tesla-- a great product, he said, by the way, as good as it gets. OK, turn this corner.
让我们沿着走廊往下走，好了，经过那张巨大的美洲湾地图，然后经过特朗普总统在大白宫草坪上与一辆大红色特斯拉的合影——顺便说一下，他说那是一款很棒的产品，好得不能再好了。好的，转过这个弯。
OK, stop there. Here we are. This next exhibit, right in front of us, is a building. See the building? Yeah. We've moved an entire federal building into the museum. The building is the Elijah Barrett Prettyman US Courthouse. And it's here because it is one of the big, gladiatorial arenas of this moment in our country's history.
好的，在那儿停下。就是这儿。下一个展品，就在我们面前，是一栋建筑。看到那栋建筑了吗？是的。我们把整栋联邦建筑搬进了博物馆。这栋建筑是Elijah Barrett Prettyman美国法院大楼。之所以放在这里，是因为它是我们国家历史此刻的一大竞技场。
Tour the courtrooms in this building, and you will find it is full of dozens of cases filed against the Trump administration-- cases about fired federal workers, cases about DOGE and Elon Musk, cases about turning around planes full of Venezuelans, including that case where the judge ordered at least one plane to turn around mid-air, and it didn't happen. That courtroom is in this building.
参观这座大楼里的法庭，你会发现这里挤满了针对特朗普政府提起的数十起案件——关于被解雇的联邦工作人员的案件，关于DOGE和埃隆·马斯克的案件，关于让满载委内瑞拉人的飞机掉头的案件，包括那个法官下令至少一架飞机半空中掉头，而它没发生的案件。那个法庭就在这栋楼里。
One of our show's editors, Laura Starecheski, volunteered to drop by and observe what we all assumed, I have to say, would be a weedy federal court hearing here, expecting to be bored with the minutia of technical legal issues, or at least some of the time. And instead, Laura found action, drama, comedy. Here is Laura's story.
我们节目的编辑之一Laura Starecheski，主动提出过来观察一下，我得说，我们都以为这会是一场沉闷的联邦法院听证会，本以为会被技术性法律问题的琐事弄得无聊，或者至少部分时间会如此。结果，Laura发现了动作、戏剧和喜剧。这是Laura的故事。
I picked a bench on the right, plaintiff side, for my day in federal court. The case I was there to see was about an executive order Trump signed in the very first week of his second term, barring transgender people from serving in the military.
我在联邦法院度过的一天，挑选了原告席右侧的一条长椅。我那天要看的案件是关于特朗普在第二个任期的第一周签署的一项行政令，禁止跨性别者在军队服役。
A group of transgender people were suing to block the executive order, claiming unconstitutional discrimination, decorated, elite, upstanding, patriotic, transgender service members, many of whom were there that day in court, sitting ramrod straight in the front row. Livelihoods and honor were at stake. This was my first federal court hearing, and I don't know what I was expecting exactly, but it wasn't this.
一群跨性别者正在起诉以阻止这项行政令，声称这是违宪歧视。这些受过嘉奖、精英、受人尊敬、爱国的跨性别服役人员，其中许多人那天都在法庭上，在第一排坐得笔直。生计和荣誉岌岌可危。这是我第一次联邦法院听证会，我不知道我到底期待什么，但绝不是这个。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: Good morning, everyone. Please be seated.
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：大家早上好。请坐。
Judge Ana C. Reyes. We had actors read the courtroom transcripts. I wasn't allowed to record there.
法官Ana C. Reyes。我们请了演员来读法庭记录。我不被允许在那里录音。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: Before we call the case this morning, I want to address some things I saw over the weekend. So some of you may have heard or heard about a TRO hearing I had on Friday. It got some press. There were a lot of social media posts about it, which I know because my friends kept teasing me about it all weekend by sending me a number of the posts.
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：在我们今天上午传唤该案之前，我想解决一些我在周末看到的事情。所以你们中的一些人可能听说过或了解我在周五举行的一场临时限制令（TRO）听证会。它上了一些新闻。有很多社交媒体帖子讨论它，我知道这一点是因为我的朋友们整个周末都在给我发帖来取笑我。
In that other case, a bunch of inspectors general recently fired by President Trump asked Judge Reyes for a Temporary Restraining Order, a TRO, to get their jobs back. Judge Reyes did not grant the TRO. Reyes is a Biden appointee, but clearly, anybody expecting her to show knee jerk sympathy for fired federal officials was going to be disappointed. On X, some conservatives were praising her, but other people were mad.
在另一起案件中，一群最近被特朗普总统解雇的监察长要求法官Reyes发布临时限制令以恢复他们的工作。Reyes法官没有批准该限制令。Reyes是拜登任命的，但显然，任何指望她对被解雇的联邦官员表现出膝跳反射式同情的做法注定会失望。在X上，一些保守派在称赞她，但其他人很生气。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: So I'm just going to give you a few examples. It started off pretty well. I got a voicemail in chambers which started, "Judge Reyes is amazing." And look, judges are people. I appreciate the compliment. I'm not going to lie. I wanted to hear more. So it continued. "Judge Reyes is an amazing fascist who cannot read because English was her second language. And it ends with she belongs in a house dress, not in a robe."
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：所以我就举几个例子。开头其实还不错。我办公室收到了一个语音留言，开头是：“Reyes法官太棒了。”听着，法官也是人。我感谢赞美。我不会撒谎。我想多听听。于是它继续说：“Reyes法官是一位了不起的法西斯分子，她读不懂书，因为英语是她的第二语言。最后说她应该穿着家居裙，而不是穿着法袍。”
Now, look, I do not think denying a TRO makes me a fascist. Also, please be assured, counsel, that I can, indeed, read. I've been able to read for about a year now.
现在，听着，我不认为拒绝TRO使我成为法西斯。另外，请放心，律师，我可以确实读懂。我大约一年前就会读了。
She's funny, I thought. But I'd come here to this courtroom to talk to the plaintiffs, to focus on them. That's what I thought the story was, not this judge or this hearing. How did this all look to the people maybe about to lose their careers and livelihoods? The plaintiffs had over 60 years of service between them, military careers going back generations, one called a passion and a family tradition, another called a deep responsibility.
我想：她很幽默。但我来这个法庭是为了和原告谈话，关注他们。我以为故事是关于这个的，而不是关于这个法官或这次听证会。对于那些可能失去职业和生计的人来说，这一切看起来是什么样的？原告们加起来有超过60年的服役经验，几代人的军事生涯，有人称之为一种热情和家族传统，另一人称之为一种深沉的责任。
The executive order was, quote, "a devastating rebuke, demoralizing." "If the ban stood, I would lose my way of life," one of the plaintiffs said in a declaration. These were people the military had spent millions of dollars to train. Some had been in combat, won medals. "Unassailable" is the word that comes to mind.
行政令被描述为“一种毁灭性的指责，令人士气低落。”“如果禁令生效，我将失去我的生活方式，”其中一名原告在声明中说。这些人是军队花了数百万美元培养的。有些人曾参与战斗，赢得过勋章。“无可动摇”是我脑海中想到的词。
But the plaintiffs would sit silently through the 5-plus hours of this hearing, as it turned out. Judge Reyes would be the star of the show. In this moment, with Congress sidelined, or distracted, or something, it's all up to the judges, it seems, to determine if the Trump administration is following the Constitution, and if not, to compel them to do so.
但事实证明，原告们在这次超过5小时的听证会中一直保持沉默。Reyes法官成了舞台上的明星。在这一刻，随着国会被边缘化，或者分心，或其他原因，看来全看这些法官来决定特朗普政府是否遵循宪法，如果不是，则强迫他们这样做。
And so I decided to watch Judge Reyes wrestle with the executive order before her. Judge Reyes is small, Latina, and just speaking for myself, intimidating. Almost immediately, once the hearing got going, her focus fell like the Eye of Sauron upon the government's lawyer, Jason Lynch. Lynch was there with two other lawyers for the Trump administration. Across the aisle from him were six lawyers on the plaintiffs' side.
所以我决定观看Reyes法官如何处理她面前的行政令。Reyes法官体型娇小，拉丁裔，仅凭我个人的观察，非常有威慑力。听证会开始后，几乎立刻，她的焦点就像索伦之眼一样落在了政府律师Jason Lynch身上。Lynch和特朗普政府的其他两名律师一起出席。在他对面的过道上，是原告方的六名律师。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: Good morning, Your Honor. Jason Lynch, Department of Justice, Civil Division, on behalf of the United States.
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：早上好，法官大人。Jason Lynch，司法部民事司，代表美国。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: You guys are outmanned.
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：你们人手不足啊。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: Indeed we are, Your Honor.
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：确实如此，法官大人。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: All right. Well, try to hang in there.
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：好吧。试着坚持住。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: Thank you.
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：谢谢。
Lynch, bearded, substantial in his suit, talking so fast, the court reporter kept pleading with him to slow down, his job was to defend the executive order. Here's some of what it says. People with a, quote, "false gender identity" can't meet the standards for military service.
Lynch留着胡子，穿着西装显得很壮实，说话速度很快，法庭速记员不停地恳求他慢点，他的工作是为行政令辩护。以下是它内容的一部分：拥有“虚假性别认同”的人无法达到军事服役的标准。
The order goes on to say, quote, "adoption of a gender identity inconsistent with an individual's sex conflicts with the soldier's commitment to an honorable, truthful, and disciplined lifestyle, even in one's personal life. A man's assertion that he is a woman, and his requirement that others honor this falsehood, is not consistent with the humility and selflessness required of a service member," end quote.
命令接着说：“采纳与个人性别不一致的性别认同，与士兵对光荣、真实和纪律严明的生活方式的承诺相冲突，即使是在个人的生活中也是如此。一个人断言自己是女性，并要求他人尊重这种虚假说法，这与军人所要求的谦逊和无私是不一致的，”引述完毕。
The implication here is that trans people are false, dishonorable, liars. I'm trans, and this kind of accusation isn't new, but I'll admit the words cut to the bone the first time I read them. And then there was this point from an earlier executive order that this one was based on, a blockbuster titled "Defending Women From Gender Ideology Extremism and Restoring Biological Truth to the Federal Government." I don't know about you, but I'd see that movie.
这里的暗示是跨性别者是虚假的、不光荣的、骗子。我是跨性别者，这种指控并不新鲜，但我承认我第一次读到这些话时，内心感到刺痛。然后，这份行政令所基于的更早的一项行政令还有一个观点，那是一部名为“保护女性免受性别意识形态极端主义侵害并恢复联邦政府生物学真理”的重磅作品。我不了解你们，但我会去看那部电影。
Anyway, the language in that executive order, if you haven't read it, goes like this-- "It is the policy of the United States to recognize two sexes, male and female. These sexes are not changeable and are grounded in fundamental and incontrovertible reality." This was the first thing that Judge Reyes kind of drilled down on. She took it up with Lynch.
无论如何，如果你还没读过那个行政令，里面的语言是这样的——“美国的政策是承认两种性别，男性和女性。这些性别不是可改变的，它们建立在基本且无可辩驳的现实之上。”这是Reyes法官钻研的第一件事。她和Lynch探讨了这个问题。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: OK, and that EO states, quote, "sex shall refer to an individual's immutable biological classification as either male or female."
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：好的，那份行政令规定，引用：“性别应指个人作为男性或女性的不可改变的生物学分类。”
EO is court speak for Executive Order.
EO是法院口语中的“行政令”。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: And it states that, quote, "It is the policy of the United States to recognize two sexes, male and female." Do you see that? Or do you remember that?
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：它规定，引用：“美国的政策是承认两种性别，男性和女性。”你看到了吗？或者你还记得吗？
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: I've misplaced my Defending Women EO, but I will take the Court's word for it.
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：我把那份“保护女性”的行政令弄丢了，但我会听从法庭的话。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: OK, it's important, so I just want you to look at it.
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：好的，这很重要，所以我只想让你看一看。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: OK. Let me get it then. So much for being well-prepared.
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：好的。那我拿一下。准备不充分真是抱歉。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: All right.
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：好的。
Lynch was standing in the well, the area in front of the judge, in which, while addressing her, he must ask even to turn his body and walk a few feet over to his desk to grab his laptop or a piece of paper with the executive order printed on it. A lawyer friend told me that the staging of all this is important. While standing in the well, the lawyers are subject to the judge's demands and requests.
Lynch站在法庭前区，即法官面前的区域，在向她陈述时，他甚至得请求允许转动身体并走几英尺到他的书桌前去拿他的笔记本电脑或印有行政令的纸。一位律师朋友告诉我，这一切的场面布置很重要。站在前区，律师必须服从法官的要求。
The judge could be like, sit down, spin around-- whatever she wants. And the lawyer would need to do it. And while everyone is in the well together, the judge limits the discussion to what is important and true. So there is at least one magical three-dimensional space in America, sized about 300 square feet, where facts are privileged. I can tell you it's real because I saw it myself.
法官可以说：坐下、转圈——随便她想怎么样。律师都需要照做。而在大家都在前区时，法官将讨论限制在重要和真实的事情上。所以美国至少有一个神奇的三维空间，大小约300平方英尺，事实在那里是享有特权的。我可以告诉你它是真实的，因为我亲眼所见。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: You understand, as a matter of biology, it's just incorrect that there are only two sexes, right?
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：你明白，从生物学角度来看，说只有两种性别是不正确的，对吧？
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: Do I understand that to be incorrect as a biological matter?
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：我明白那作为生物学问题是不正确的吗？
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: Yes, it is incorrect as a biological matter. You understand that, right?
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：是的，作为生物学问题这是不正确的。你明白这一点，对吧？
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: I don't understand that to be incorrect.
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：我不认为那是不正确的。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: Well, you understand that not everyone has an XX or an XY chromosome, right?
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：好吧，你明白并不是每个人都有XX或XY染色体，对吧？
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: Well, honestly, no, I'm not prepared to--
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：嗯，老实说，没有，我没准备好去——
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: I mean, it's actually kind of a really important point because this executive order is premised on an assertion that's not biologically correct. There are anywhere near about 30 different intersex examples. So someone who does not have just an XX or XY chromosome is not just male or female, they're intersex.
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：我是说，这其实是一个非常重要的点，因为这项行政令的前提是一个生物学上不正确的断言。有大约30种不同的双性人例子。所以那些不仅仅有XX或XY染色体的人不仅仅是男性或女性，他们是双性人。
And there are over 30 potential different intersex examples. We've got genetic differences. We have people with XXX chromosomes. We have androgen insensitivity, XY genetically, but may have female external sex characteristics and internally have testes. There's a 5-alpha reductase deficiency that causes changes in testosterone metabolism.
而且有超过30种潜在不同的双性人例子。我们有遗传差异。我们有XXX染色体的人。我们有雄激素不敏感，遗传上是XY，但可能有女性外部性别特征，内部有睾丸。有一种5-α还原酶缺乏症，会导致睾酮代谢的变化。
She was deep in this material. I hadn't been able to tell up until this point if Reyes was leaning in a particular direction with this case. Now, I could see the things she loves-- science, rational thought, facts. Later, in this and other hearings, there would be Star Trek references, Beyoncé, side speech on Newtonian physics. For now, homework for the lawyers.
她对这些材料钻研很深。在那一点之前，我一直看不出Reyes在处理此案时是否倾向于某个方向。现在，我可以看到她热爱的东西——科学、理性思考、事实。后来，在这次和其他听证会上，会出现《星际迷航》的引用、碧昂丝，关于牛顿物理学的侧面论述。目前，是律师的家庭作业。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: I'm happy to have you guys brief this more if you want, but I'm telling you right now that there are people who are neither male nor female. And so the premise of the executive order is just incorrect. And my question to you is-- and if you want to talk about this tomorrow, that's fine. But my question to you is, what do I do with the fact that the entire order is premised on an incorrect biological assessment?
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：我很高兴你们如果想的话可以对此进行更多总结，但我现在就告诉你们，有些人既不是男性也不是女性。所以行政令的前提是不正确的。我的问题是——如果你想明天再讨论这个问题，那没关系。但我的问题是，如果整个命令的前提基于不正确的生物学评估，我该怎么办？
This was the first big thwack Judge Reyes took at the validity of the executive order. Lynch didn't have a satisfying answer. Judge Reyes said he had to write up a brief on the biology of sex for her.
这是Reyes法官对行政令有效性的第一次重击。Lynch没有给出令人满意的答案。Reyes法官说他必须为她写一份关于性别生物学的摘要。
Around this time, I looked over at a large sketchpad on the lap of an older white man sitting next to me. He was sketching with a pencil some beautifully drawn geometric shapes. Next to those were lists of numbers. Next to the numbers, one row labeled "direct shots," one labeled "indirect shots."
大约在那个时候，我看向坐在我旁边的一位老白人膝盖上的一本大画本。他正在用铅笔勾勒出一些画得很美的几何图形。旁边是数字列表。数字旁边，一行标着“直接射击”，一行标着“间接射击”。
Whoa. Was he keeping score, tracking how many points the judge landed and how many Lynch did? There were percentages. How long had he been following this case? There were layers of sophistication to observing a hearing like this that I couldn't have imagined.
哇。他在记分吗，追踪法官落地了多少分，Lynch落地了多少分？有百分比。他关注这个案子多久了？观察这样的听证会有我想象不到的复杂层面。
I asked the guy later on a break. He told me he's retired. Court watching is his hobby. Comes here to the federal court building four or five times a week, just for fun. On the notepad, he was gaming out scenarios while he listened to the judge for his other hobby-- backgammon.
我在休息时问了那个家伙。他告诉我他退休了。观看庭审是他的爱好。他每周来四五次联邦法院大楼，只是为了好玩。在记事本上，他在一边听法官讲话一边思考其他场景，为了他的另一个爱好——双陆棋。
When an executive order gets challenged in court, there's this legal concept that gets applied, a basic test that has to pass. It's usually easy, like a limbo bar 10 feet in the air that you can just walk under. Does the order pass rational basis scrutiny? Meaning, is the government singling out this group for a legitimate reason? Is this order justified?
当行政令在法庭上受到挑战时，会应用一种法律概念，即必须通过的一项基本测试。它通常很容易，就像一个离地10英尺高的凌波舞横杆，你可以直接走过去。该命令是否通过了合理基础审查？意思是，政府是否为了正当理由将这个群体挑出来？这项命令有正当理由吗？
But with this executive order, it was hard to find a justification because none was offered. No military officials in uniform stepped up to testify. In fact, there were no complaints at all submitted to the court from anyone in the military that trans people disrupt unit cohesion or harm troop readiness, as the order claims. No real evidence, just the naked assertion that trans people are unfit to serve.
但对于这项行政令，很难找到正当理由，因为根本没提供。没有身穿制服的军事官员站出来作证。事实上，法庭没有收到任何来自军队的投诉，称跨性别者破坏了部队凝聚力或损害了部队战备状态，正如命令所称的那样。没有真实的证据，只有赤裸裸的断言，称跨性别者不适合服役。
So without convincing evidence, Judge Reyes was left with the words in the order itself, and Jason Lynch standing in front of her to answer a very basic question-- is this order just demeaning and discriminatory in a common sense way?
所以由于缺乏令人信服的证据，Reyes法官只能面对命令本身的话语，而Jason Lynch站在她面前回答一个非常基本的问题——这项命令是否仅仅是以一种常识性的方式贬低和歧视？
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: I mean, if I called you a liar, would you find that demeaning?
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：我的意思是，如果我叫你骗子，你会觉得那是在贬低你吗？
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: So I assume the Court is asking in a constitutionally relevant sense whether--
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：所以我假设法庭是在问在一个宪法相关的意义上，是否——
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: I'm just-- no, I'm asking in a common sense way.
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：我只是——不，我是在问以一种常识性的方式。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: So I don't have an answer in a common sense way, Your Honor.
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：所以法官大人，我没有一个常识性的答案。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: OK, you don't know if you can tell me that categorizing an entire group of people as dishonorable, lying, undisciplined, whether at work or at home-- so you can't tell me, sitting here today on behalf of the government, whether someone would consider that demeaning?
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：好的，你不知道是否可以告诉我，将整整一群人归类为不光荣的、说谎的、无纪律的，无论是工作还是在家里——所以你今天代表政府坐在这里，无法告诉我是否有人会认为那是贬低？
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: I don't have a view to express on that question, Your Honor.
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：法官大人，我没有观点可以表达。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: Quote, "A man's assertion that he is a woman and his requirement that others honor this falsehood is not consistent with the humility and selflessness required for a service member," end quote. What's the record and the evidence-- what's the evidence in the record before me to support this assertion?
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：引用：“一个人断言自己是女性，并要求他人尊重这种虚假说法，这与军人所要求的谦逊和无私是不一致的，”引述完毕。在我面前的记录和证据中，支持这个断言的证据是什么？
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: For-- the same answer with the same caveats as before, Your Honor.
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：对于——同样的回答，带着和之前同样的保留意见，法官大人。
I don't have an answer. I don't have a view to express. I can't say. There were silver clock hands mounted up on the wood paneled wall above Lynch's side of the courtroom. They were stuck just after 9:00 AM. They never moved. And he repeated the same answers over and over and over.
我没有答案。我没有观点可以表达。我说不上来。在Lynch一边法庭的木镶板墙上装着银色的钟表指针。它们卡在9点刚过。它们从未动过。他一次又一次地重复同样的回答。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: Would you consider being called dishonest, demeaning?
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：你认为被称为不诚实是在贬低吗？
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: I think I'm going to have the same answer, Your Honor, which is that we don't concede that it's a constitutionally relevant expression.
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：我想我会给出同样的回答，法官大人，那就是我们不承认这是一个宪法相关的表达。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: What about immodest?
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：那么不知羞耻呢？
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: Same answer, Your Honor.
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：同样的回答，法官大人。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: What about lacking integrity? Can you at least give me lacking integrity? Anyone with common sense would say that being called someone who lacks integrity, people who have sworn to take an oath, who have sworn an oath to defend the country with their lives, would you consider that to be, as a commonsensical manner, demeaning? Or you can't even say that?
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：那么缺乏诚信呢？你至少能给我“缺乏诚信”吗？任何有常识的人都会说，被称为缺乏诚信的人，那些宣誓过要效忠、宣誓要用生命保卫国家的人，你认为那种方式，作为一种常识性的方式，是在贬低他们吗？或者你连这个都说不出来？
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: I'd have to give you the same answer, Your Honor.
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：我得给你同样的回答，法官大人。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: Would it be fair to say that excluding a group of people from military service based on unsupported assertions that they are liars, immodest, lack integrity, are undisciplined, and are dishonorable, would you agree with me that particularly, where there is no support for any of those assertions, that that is animated by animus?
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：如果你同意我的观点，即基于他们是骗子、不知羞耻、缺乏诚信、无纪律和不光荣的无根据断言而将一群人排除在兵役之外——你同意我的观点吗，特别是在那些断言都没有支持的情况下，这是由敌意激发的？
Animus-- here, a legal term, meaning roughly, hostility towards a specific group. Even if, say, a president doesn't like a certain category of people, the Constitution says the government can't treat them differently or worse than others without a sufficient reason. And if there is no sufficient reason, or any discernible reason for the executive order, the judge can conclude that it's simply discriminatory, and therefore unconstitutional.
敌意——这里是一个法律术语，大概指对特定群体的敌对。即使说总统不喜欢某类人，宪法也说政府不能在没有正当理由的情况下对待他们，或者比其他人更糟糕。如果行政令没有正当理由，或者任何可辨别的理由，法官可以得出结论，它仅仅是歧视性的，因此是违宪的。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: I want to know whether this executive order signed by the president of the United States, who calls an entire category of people dishonest, dishonorable, undisciplined, immodest, who lack integrity, people who have taken an oath to defend this country, people who have been under fire, people who have received medals for taking fire for this country, I want to know from the government, whether that language expresses animus.
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：我想知道美国总统签署的这份行政令，称整整一类人是不诚实的、不光荣的、无纪律的、不知羞耻的、缺乏诚信的，这些人宣誓要保卫这个国家，这些人曾处于战火中，这些人曾因为保卫这个国家而获得奖章，我想从政府那里知道，这种语言是否表达了敌意。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: And I have the same answer as before, Your Honor.
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：法官大人，我和之前有同样的回答。
Lynch seemed to be in the awkward position of not having a counterargument, and also having no way to answer her questions without saying something that could hurt his case.
Lynch似乎处在一个尴尬的位置，没有反驳论点，也没有办法回答她的问题而不说出可能损害他案件的话。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: Does that express animus?
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：那是否表达了敌意？
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: So--
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：所以——
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: Yes? No? I don't know?
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：是？不？我不知道？
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: Not in any constitutionally--
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：在任何宪法相关的——
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: No, in a common sense way.
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：不，以一种常识性的方式。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: I understand, Your Honor, that as you said on Thursday, you may write an opinion that says the government refused to answer that question or was unable to answer that question. I don't have an answer for you.
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：法官大人，我明白，正如您在周四所说的那样，您可能会写一份意见书，说政府拒绝回答该问题或无法回答该问题。我没有答案给您。
I almost felt bad for Lynch, but he stayed the course, kept stonewalling, which is either the perfect joke for this spot, or the worst. Reyes paused, thought, tried a different tack.
我几乎为Lynch感到难过，但他坚持到底，保持阻挠，这要么是这个职位的完美笑话，要么是最糟糕的。Reyes停顿、思考、尝试了不同的方法。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: ACTOR AS ANA REYES: You know, you're a lawyer. You know how important integrity is to your profession, right?
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：你知道，你是律师。你知道诚信对你的职业有多重要，对吧？
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: Yes, Your Honor.
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：是的，法官大人。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: All right. I made standing orders when I was in the back. My new standing orders say that no one who has graduated from UVA Law School can appear before me. So I need you to sit down, please. I need you to sit down.
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：好的。我在后面下达了常设命令。我的新常设命令说，任何从弗吉尼亚大学法学院毕业的人都不能出现在我面前。所以我需要你坐下，请。我需要你坐下。
Lynch actually did go sit down. He left the microphone, awkwardly circumnavigated a large table on the government side, and sat with the other two lawyers. An invisible but collective cringe rippled across the courtroom.
Lynch确实去坐下了。他离开了麦克风，尴尬地绕过了政府方的一张大桌子，坐在了另外两名律师旁边。一种无形但集体的畏缩在法庭上荡漾开来。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: And the reason I don't want people from UVA Law School appearing before me is because, for no reason I'm going to give you, I think they're all liars and lack integrity and are undisciplined and can't possibly meet the high rigors of being a lawyer for the government. Now, if I actually had that standing order, would that be demeaning-- come back up-- to people from UVA Law School?
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：我不希望来自弗吉尼亚大学法学院的人出现在我面前的原因是，因为我不给你们任何理由，我认为他们都是骗子，缺乏诚信，无纪律，不可能达到作为政府律师的高标准严要求。现在，如果我确实有那项常设命令，那会是在贬低——回来——来自弗吉尼亚大学法学院的人吗？
Lynch made his way around the table again and went back up to the microphone.
Lynch再次绕过桌子，回到了麦克风前。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR OF JASON LYNCH: Because you actually prevented me from appearing in front of you on that basis, I think it would be fair if courts were subject to the same kind of scrutiny to demand that you support the reason for having done that.
（主题）Jason Lynch的演员：因为您确实阻止了我在此基础上出现在您面前，我想如果法院受到同样的审查要求您支持这样做出的原因，那将是公平的。
This was as close as Lynch came, as far as I could tell, to conceding a point. It's fair for Judge Reyes to ask the question, to ask the government for one legitimate reason for banning transgender people from the military. Trump's Justice Department filed a complaint about Judge Reyes for this forced thought exercise about UVA Law School. They asked for an investigation, said she had tried to embarrass Jason Lynch.
据我所知，这是Lynch最接近承认一点的时候。Reyes法官提出这个问题是公平的，要求政府给出一个禁止跨性别者服兵役的正当理由。特朗普的司法部就这一强迫思维练习针对Reyes法官提出了投诉。他们要求调查，说她试图让Jason Lynch难堪。
Judge Reyes was open to hearing a reason why trans people should not serve in the military. Indeed, she asked for one, practically pleaded. I couldn't count the times over the course of this hearing and the ones that followed that Judge Reyes asked the government lawyers to offer any evidence, any testimony, any studies, any data that would support their case for the executive order. She gave them time. She asked for research and written briefs, anything or anyone.
Reyes法官很乐意听到跨性别者不应该在军队服役的理由。事实上，她要求一个，实际上是恳求。我数不清她在这次听证会和接下来的听证会中多少次要求政府律师提供任何证据、证词、研究、数据来支持他们支持行政令的理由。她给了他们时间。她要求研究和书面摘要，任何东西或任何人。
(SUBJECT) ACTOR AS ANA REYES: If you want to have-- if you want to get me an officer of the United States military who's willing to get on the stand and say that because of pronoun usage, the US military is less prepared than it needs to be, I will be the first to give you a box of cigars. You have until-- you have 10 days to find me a person, find a declarant, anyone who's a commissioned officer, to get on the stand and say that. And I'm going to want them on the stand, not just in writing, all right?
（主题）饰演Ana Reyes的演员：如果你想——如果你想给我找一个美国军官，愿意站在证人席上说因为代词的使用，美国军队准备不足，我将是第一个给你一盒雪茄的人。你有直到——你有10天时间给我找一个人，找一个陈述人，任何一个军官，站在证人席上说那话。我想要他们站在证人席上，而不只是以书面形式，好吗？
The government never produced any witnesses. No military person took the stand to argue for the executive order. Judge Reyes took a few weeks to rule. Meanwhile, an official policy came down from the Department of Defense. The policy instructed the military to identify trans people within 30 days, and required them to either leave on their own or be forced out.
政府从未提供任何证人。没有军人站在证人席上为行政令辩护。Reyes法官花了几个星期做出裁决。与此同时，国防部出台了一项官方政策。该政策指示军方在30天内识别跨性别者，并要求他们要么自行离开，要么被强行赶走。
So across the military, trans people started to get singled out by their commanders, first, slowly, in dribs and drabs, and then faster, as more and more got scooped up and sidelined in different ways. One plaintiff told me she had been yanked from her unit as a medic in a combat zone in the Middle East and put on a plane back to the US so the Army could start the process of discharging her.
所以整个军队中，跨性别者开始被他们的指挥官挑出来，起初是缓慢地、零星地，然后速度加快，因为越来越多的人被以各种方式带走和边缘化。一名原告告诉我，她作为中东战区的一名军医被从部队拉出来，被送上一架回美国的飞机，这样军队就可以开始解除她职务的程序。
Another, a congressional fellow in the Air Force serving at the Pentagon, was put on administrative leave and told to prepare to be separated. That's the military term for kicked out. A petty officer showed up for surgery at a Navy Medical Center in Virginia. He was pulled off a gurney after being given anesthesia, but before the surgeon began the procedure, and told to leave the hospital.
另一名在五角大楼服役的空军国会研究员被行政停职，并被告知准备好被分离。那是军队解雇的术语。一名士官在弗吉尼亚州的一家海军医疗中心接受手术时出现。他在麻醉后、但外科医生开始手术前被从担架上拉下来，并被告知离开医院。
When Judge Reyes finally ruled, she wrote that she was blocking the military policy. She found that the policy and the executive order that it was based on violated equal protection rights in the Constitution.
当Reyes法官最终裁决时，她写道她正在阻止这项军事政策。她发现该政策以及它所基于的行政令违反了宪法中的平等保护权。
She wrote, "The military ban is soaked in animus and dripping with pretext. Its language is unabashedly demeaning. Its policy stigmatizes transgender persons as inherently unfit, and its conclusions bear no relation to fact." Her ruling said the military could not discharge transgender people just for being trans, and they have to bring anyone who's been put on leave back to active duty.
她写道：“军事禁令浸透了敌意，充满了借口。其语言毫不掩饰地具有贬低性。其政策将跨性别者污名化为本质上不适合，其结论与事实无关。”她的裁决称军方不能仅仅因为是跨性别者就解雇跨性别者，他们必须将任何被停职的人带回现役。
This week, the Trump administration appealed the case to a higher court. As I finish this story, it's unclear whether the military will be allowed to discharge transgender service members or whether Judge Reyes's ruling will stand.
本周，特朗普政府将此案上诉至更高法院。当我完成这个故事时，尚不清楚军方是否会被允许解雇跨性别服役人员，或者Reyes法官的裁决是否会维持。
If you'll permit me one small digression at this late stage, back in the courtroom, during the hearings, there was one other court watcher, an even older man, with jeans drooping off his skinny butt, dedicated, clearly irregular, not always coherent. At one point, apropos of nothing, he called out into the courtroom, referencing Brer Rabbit. They threw me into that briar patch, he said. Nothing worse than being thrown into a briar patch on a nice, warm, spring-like day.
如果允许我在后期做一个小小的离题，回到法庭上，在听证会期间，还有另一位法院观察员，一个更老的人，穿着牛仔裤从他瘦小的屁股上垂下来，敬业，显然不规律，并不总是连贯。在某一点上，他莫名其妙地在法庭里大声叫喊，提到了布雷尔兔（Brer Rabbit）。他们把我扔进了荆棘丛里，他说。在温暖、类似春天的日子里，没有什么比被扔进荆棘丛里更糟糕的了。
I think it's fair to say that Trump's executive order, with its almost absurdly strong and cruel language, threw a lot of people into the briar patch-- plaintiffs, first and foremost, their families, other trans service members, lawyers, judges, me. It started a chain of events, and we might still be at the beginning. This case could take a while to wind its way through the courts, months, maybe years, making this the kind of situation that's apparently a little too easy to get into and very, very difficult to get out of.
我认为公平地说，特朗普的行政令，以其近乎荒谬的强烈和残酷的语言，把很多人扔进了荆棘丛——原告，首当其冲，他们的家人，其他跨性别服役人员，律师，法官，还有我。它引发了一连串事件，我们可能还处于起步阶段。此案可能需要一段时间才能在法院审理，几个月，也许几年，这使它成为那种显然太容易进入、却非常非常难以摆脱的情况。
Laura Starecheski is one of the editors of our show. The actors were Veronica Cruz and Dave Shalansky.
Laura Starecheski是我们节目的编辑之一。演员是Veronica Cruz和Dave Shalansky。
Well, our visit to the Museum of Now was produced and edited by Nancy Updike and Chana Joffe-Walt. They also sit on the museum's board and construction committee and say that if we need to visit again, they can pull some strings for us. They promise they're going to stay on the board, even if the president decides to make himself the chairman.
好吧，我们的“当下博物馆”之行是由Nancy Updike和Chana Joffe-Walt制作和编辑的。她们也是博物馆董事会和施工委员会的成员，她们说如果我们需要再次参观，她们可以为我们走后门。她们承诺会留在董事会，即使总统决定让自己成为主席。
Other people put together today's show-- Phia Bennin, Michael Comite, Angela Gervasi, Cassie Howley, Valerie Kipnis, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Ike Sriskandarajah, Lilly Sullivan, Amelia Schonbek, Christopher Swetala, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
还有其他人组成了今天的节目——Phia Bennin, Michael Comite, Angela Gervasi, Cassie Howley, Valerie Kipnis, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Ike Sriskandarajah, Lilly Sullivan, Amelia Schonbek, Christopher Swetala, 以及 Diane Wu。我们的总编辑是 Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的高级编辑是 David Kestenbaum。我们的执行编辑是 Emanuele Berry。
Special thanks today to Eli Hager, Tom Cartwright, Molly Mitchell, Liz Goss, Adam Cohen, Kathryn Bettis, Alex Guerrero, Sonja West, Kat-- no last name, you know you are-- Andrew Zitcer, Yowei Shaw, Karen Ortiz, Annika Barber, and Public Radio station KCRW in Los Angeles, where I've been recording this week. They have been so nice. Special thanks to Phillip Richards, Sarah Sweeney, and Jennifer Ferro.
今天特别感谢 Eli Hager, Tom Cartwright, Molly Mitchell, Liz Goss, Adam Cohen, Kathryn Bettis, Alex Guerrero, Sonja West, Kat——没姓，你知道你是谁—— Andrew Zitcer, Yowei Shaw, Karen Ortiz, Annika Barber，以及洛杉矶的公共广播电台 KCRW，我本周在那儿录音。他们一直很好。特别感谢 Phillip Richards, Sarah Sweeney 和 Jennifer Ferro。
A quick programming note-- we've been making these bonus episodes every two weeks for months now for our Life Partners. In the most recent one, a former producer named Alex Blumberg begins a little tour of This American Life stories to cover the news stuff. I have to say, it's like this weird time capsule of all kinds of feelings and events. If you want to hear those or hear the many, many non-news, very fun bonus episodes that we've made, go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners.
一个小节目通知——几个月来，我们一直为我们的“生活伴侣”每两周制作一次奖励剧集。在最近的一期中，一位名叫 Alex Blumberg 的前制作人开始了一次关于《美国生活》故事的小巡回，以报道新闻内容。我得说，这就像一个包含各种感受和事件的怪异时间胶囊。如果你想收听这些，或者收听我们制作的许多许多非新闻、非常有趣的奖励剧集，请访问 thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
《美国生活》是由公共广播交易所 PRX 分发给公共广播电台的。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, that man loves his prop comedy. Like, he'll take a red cape and Clark Kent glasses, put them on a slab of sidewalk, and proudly say--
一如既往，感谢我们节目的联合创始人 Torey Malatia 先生。你知道，那个人热爱他的道具喜剧。比如，他会拿一件红披风和克拉克·肯特眼镜，把它们放在一段人行道上，自豪地说——
It's not just concrete, it's super concrete.
它不仅仅是混凝土，它是超级混凝土。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周回来会有更多《美国生活》的故事。